I cannot believe this you are one of the
most recognizable people in the world
but and sleepy but you often get
mistaken for ray Fiennes yes I do I find
that very hard to believe because I
don't even really see I mean there's a
tiny bit of a similarity there's repeat
of you so if he saw a raised profile we
have very similar Neanderthal foreheads
and noses and he has successfully
effective on a Tony Award for playing
Hamlet on stage about 14 years ago I
have been complimented complimented on
my Hamlet and so you've had people and
these are people that stop you and say I
love your were like going on there was
one time it's actually a touching story
if you'll forgive me for sharing away
it's a time to talk show I'm sure we're
of time no no no no no please
I was with my beloved wife we were in
the we were in Paris staying at this
Plaza Athenee hotel this beautiful hotel
I was publicized in some movie I can't
remember but we're walking through the
corridor and there were two elderly
ladies and two under their husbands
elderly gentlemen they stood up as we
passed and this lady Kim says excuse me
can I interrupt you for a second of
course what he says well these are my
husband's they're about to go up to the
Normandy beaches fiftieth anniversary
they haven't been there for since the
battle and that's like I know I'm
already coming out in goosebumps and she
says we've admired your work so much I'm
like I work in movies yeah
these guys liberated Europe so she's
talking away and these gentlemen they're
still standing and out of respect I'm
feeling that sighs you know yeah and she
said would you mind signing something
for us I said core civil and she picks
up these these incredible
menus they have in these these expensive
hotels said would you sign that source
they will to Mildred and John summer we
got you know and I better get the pen
and says we loved you in The English
Patient so I signed it to Mildred John
lots of love wreath
[Applause]
all right there's no way could I burst
their bubble no way at that point no at
that point you did the exact right thing
yeah that was no way am I gonna say
excuse me
[Applause]